[Music]
[Applause]
Bill plashy LA Times sports columnist
and contributor to around the horn and
uh Bill's latest column uh in supposed
breakthrough USC season Lincoln Riley
has been a bust as USC has cow coming up
next besides the loss what bothered you
the most about this weekend
bill just the way the team loss the the
the USC defense continues to just be
horrible and Lincoln Riley won't do
anything about it the offense is
disconnected and Lincoln Ry won't do
anything about it and then after the
game really bothers him for the first
time in USC history The Players weren't
allowed to talk to the media because
guess L Ry want to avoid all the noise
this is a town of noise this is a town
built on noise this is this is La you
don't avoid the media you don't avoid
accountability and you don't avoid the
educational process that letting kids
talk to the reporters you know gains
them the whole program is just in a it's
a mess and Lincoln Riley was paid $10
million a year to fix this last year all
these Championship hopes so yes I was
kind of bothered by everything Dan is
the honeymoon
over absolutely over they they were
booing them in the Coliseum which which
rarely happens people outside the
program are questioning it donors are
wondering where their money's going yes
the was over he last year was a great
turnaround this year they have a
returning High Trophy winner $10 million
coach 20 Great Blue Chip
transfers supposedly a national
championship team and they're already
out of it and it's not it's it's still
October so yes the honeymoon is over for
Lincoln
Riley do you think he h didn't allow
Caleb Williams to talk because he was
protecting Caleb Williams or Lincoln
Riley's protecting Lincoln Riley
I think he's trying to protect himself
in His image and the program's image and
it really just does that does so much
damage that that's part of how these
kids that's part of what what what they
get out of college is learning how to
deal with the media learning how to talk
in public situations learning how to
deal with the public and they cost them
an opportunity and Caleb hasn't talked
twice this year after games what other
team other Sporter the highman trophy
winner doesn't talk after after games
that that that's crazy
so yes he's he's trying to hide the kids
and he's trying to hide himself and it's
not working not in this town this town's
too transparent it's too much demand for
accountability and there's too much of a
call for championships you don't come
here as the hottest coach in America and
promise championships and don't deliver
okay so what's next here Caleb can go to
the pros and be gone with all of
this yeah it's so funny I mean i' I've
been saying out here that I think both
of them could be gone I mean obviously
Caleb C the question with Caleb is how
long does he stick around this mess I
mean if once they get out of the if they
lose to Washington or Oregon they can't
win a TR pwell
Championship why is he still playing for
USC why does he he just take the rest of
the year off because he's already the
number one draft pick all he can do is
hurt himself and you wonder how much
Lincoln Riley wants to stick around for
another rebuilding with another new
quarterback I can see them both going I
said this before I can see them both
going to the like the Bears in a package
deal I can see both of them going pro so
I think any think is possible yeah but
why would I want Lincoln Riley if I'm
the
Bears well he's the quarterback
Whisperer I mean he's I don't think the
Bears care that he doesn't let players
talk to media that he doesn't coach
defense the Bears would care that he's
got you know he Grooms he try
quarterbacks and he and he wins you know
he wins a lot of college games and I
think that that's all the NFL cares
about I mean I'm thinking and and he he
doesn't he doesn't run a program in a
big city very well but I don't think
that matters to I think all they care
about is getting a guy who can get if
they get the number one draft Pi they
get Caleb Williams a guy who Caleb
Williams will listen to and respond to
and that's him I think I think it makes
perfect sense yeah but it felt like and
I maybe I'm reading between the lines
Lincoln Riley kind of called out Caleb
Williams in the Notre Dame loss by
saying you know there there were guys
open and that surprised me a little bit
that he was critiquing his quarterback
yeah he's he's called him out twice now
he's he kind of infer that yeah yet on
Saturday night the call him as well but
I think Caleb knows this guy helped him
get a heist in Trophy I mean I think and
I think their relationship runs deeper
than you know a few smoke singals after
games I think I think these guys are
pretty much tied at the hip and I can
see him and Caleb is GNA decide where he
wants to wants to be drafted I mean if a
team gets the number one pick and and he
didn't want to go there he's he's he's
gonna put up a fuss so he can help
engineer Riley going to wherever he's
going I think it's I think it's a two
for one deal is totally possible talking
to Bill plashy LA Times uh Sports
columnist also contributor to a Around
the Horn give me the uh football
hierarchy in Los Angeles like Rams USC
Chargers most important USC USC
football's way up here it's it's it's up
with the Lakers and Dodgers I mean
people are really into USC football
that's why this Lincoln R I think is so
terrible and then you come way down to
the
Rams and you I'm trying to find the
charg yeah and it's it's no fault of
their own they're trying they're a good
organiz hard I me because they're
supposed to be winning they're not
winning so they they fallen off the map
so that's and then whe UCLA football is
probably equal with the Rams the Rams
aren't the biggest game in town by far
yeah uh the Lakers season opens up
tomorrow night what are the realistic
expectations I think if ad and LeBron
can stay healthy the entire year they
can compete for a championship however
there's no way they stay healthy for the
entire year now give me the realistic
one realistic is probably fourth in the
west maybe get a couple rounds in in the
postseason I just don't see at some
point ages got to catch up to LeBron at
some point he he can't keep being
Superman he's 30 39 years old 21 Seasons
I can't see him playing at the same
level he's played in
ad never had hadn't played a full season
in his his entire career so he's still
brittle so I think probably there all
the all the ads they made all the great
consistency they've done and all the
great team that they were at the end of
the last year if those guys don't stay
healthy they aren't going anywhere and I
don't see them staying healthy I like
the roster but I love the roster but
it's it's all based on ad LeBron yeah
it's all based on on them everything you
it's a pretty little toys around them
but it's all based on what they can do
if they can stay on the court and that's
yet to be seen so that that's a problem
with them but I but again if they're
healthy it's great but I don't see that
happening are you on around the horn
today no I'm on the round the horn
Wednesday watch Wednesday I'm one of the
oldest panelists now J I started about
being the young
guy I'm now the old guy Dan yeah but I
want you on today bill because the USC's
loss over the week who's programming
this show I wish they could adjust it
yeah because I'd be all well maybe
they'll wait till Wednesday well I
predicted Dan I predicted in my column I
predicted a month ago the USC would go
12 and0 so I gotta I've gotta answer
that prediction yeah that's how good
they're supposed to be that's how good
they're that's how
diso oh so I can't blame you I have to
blame them for you making that
prediction yes yes it was their fault
and so I'm sure I'm taking points away
from from you right now Tony R is sure
will do that they will do that on
Wednesday I'm going to say we start with
12 points you're negative2 to start on
it's gonna be it's gonna be it's gonna
be a blood be a blood bath I'm with so
yeah tune in Wednesday to see me get
muted to Hell thank you Bill good to
talk to you thanks D thanks Bill plashy
LA Times sports colist yeah forgot Bill
had him going 12 and0
ouch cuz they could lose probably three
more games